[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition spéciale on ce
jeudi 7 mai sur tv 78
gimont iii avant le début du
déconfinement en france et le premier
ministre edouard philippe a présenté
tout à l'heure le plan du gouvernement
pour cette nouvelle phase qui s'ouvre
avec des spécificités par territoire sur
la carte du déconfinement la voici les
yvelines malgré une circulation du virus
qui a b c restant rouge comme pour
l'ensemble de l'ile-de-france le
déconfinement il sera donc plus strictes
pas de réouverture des collèges et des
parcs et jardins qui resteront fermés
lundi
pas de confinement obligatoire pour
autant le gouvernement invite cependant
les personnes âgées et vulnérables a
continué d'observer le confinement
le télétravail devra être privilégiée
les déplacements limités au strict
minimum les commerces enfin pourront
rouvrir sauf pour les cafés bars et
restaurants ainsi que pour ceux situés
dans les centres commerciaux de plus de
40 mille mètres carrés les yvelines où
444 personnes sont décédées dans les
hôpitaux des suites du coc vide 19 c 2 2
plus en 24 heures mais le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation a
baissé encore hier sept cent soixante
patients étaient hospitalisés dans le
département 75 en réanimation
et puis à 1530 le nombre de personnes
guéries du coronavirus est revenu à
domicile
à partir de lundi le déconfinement qui
va donc de pair avec la réouverture des
écoles primaires et maternelles dans un
premier temps une rentrée et souple qui
se veut progressive et sur la base du
volontariat rappelé emmanuel macron lors
de sa visite à poissy mardi le président
de la république qui pour la réussite de
ce retour en classe s'appuie sur les
maires des communes qui ont pris chacun
leur décision coup d'oeil au calendrier
de cette réouverture des écoles dans les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
à partir du 12 mai les élèves de
guyancourt magny les hameaux trappe et
voisins le bretonneux reprendront
progressivement le chemin des bancs
scolaires pour l encours la verrière les
clayes sous bois et plaisir ce sera dès
le jeudi 14 mai et à coignières et
montigny le bretonneux on a choisi la
semaine suivante celle du 18 mai pour
cette rentrée
chaque commune à ces dispositions
spécifiques et progressive et n'hésitez
pas à consulter les sites internet
doivent ou à rapprocher des services de
la vie scolaire à plaisir par exemple où
la rentrée je vous le disais
s'effectuera à partir du 12 mai pour
appliquer le protocole la municipalité a
procédé à une désinfection de toutes ces
écoles et des distributeurs de gel
hydroalcoolique seront également dans
toutes les salles du savon et des essuie
mains disponible en grande quantité
marquage au sol également pour faire
respecter la distanciation et des jeux
condamné dans les cours de récréation
les repas se feront à la cantine
directement servi à table et seuls les
enfants défavorisés dont les parents
exercent des activités dites
prioritaires pourront faire cette
rentrée dans un premier temps des
décisions prises au bout de 35 réunions
de travail à plaisir on écoute la mère
joséphine coleman ce berger on a tout
fait depuis 15 jours pour que tout soit
prêt pour le 11
c'est à dire le jour de la rentrée des
enseignants où ils viennent pour faire
leur formation sanitaire et
l'installation des classes comme ça des
enseignants auront le lundi le mardi
voir le mercredi 6 était nécessaire
avant d'accueillir les enfants nous ici
à plaisir on a dans les écoles
maternelles un quota de entre cinq et
dix enfants en maternelle maximum et en
élémentaire entre 10 et 15 enfants
maximum en tenant compte que bien sûr on
priorise l'acceptation des enfants dont
on a eu la liste par le gouvernement
à partir de là il ya des écoles qui vont
pouvoir en plus des enfants qui sont
prioritaires et accueillir d'autres
enfants de parents qu'ils ne sont pas et
dans ses requêtes des écoles le plan qui
sera fait avec les enfants prioritaire
donc tout ça sur une période je dirais
déjà une quinzaine de jours jusqu'au
pratiquement fin mai et ensuite selon
l'assouplissant on verra comment on peut
augmenter le nombre d'enfants a accepté
dans les écoles à montigny le bretonneux
le maire jean-luc ourgaud fait partie de
ces 67 élus à avoir demandé dans une
tribune le report de la rentrée scolaire
la municipalité a fait d'ailleurs un
sondage dans sa ville et sur 2400
habitants interrogés 35 % ne souhaitent
pas remettre leurs enfants à l'école
volontariat également en progressivité
donc pour cette rentrée qui seront
appliqués à montigny le bretonneux ou la
rentrée sera la fête à partir du 18 mai
écoutez ça va être une reprise
progressive
déjà moi je n'ai je n'ai pas souhaité
rouvrir les maternelle petite section
parce que là le protocole sanitaire est
complètement ahurissant compréhensible
mais à gruissan pour mettre en oeuvre
pour prendre un exemple que les petites
caisses de jouer il fallait désinfecter
tous les jouets les uns après les autres
et les feutres légaux donc là j'ai dit
hop on n'ouvre pas maintenant on verra
un peu plus tard plus tard et donc la
reprise va se faire progressivement à
partir du lundi 18 sur le principe de 15
enfants maximum par classe
donc il y aura des deux groupes le lundi
le mardi et deux autres groupes le jeudi
et le vendredi
ça va s'échelonner je pense qu'à partir
du 25 mai je pense qu'on pourra
accueillir plus d'enfants pour les
informations relatives à votre commune
une nouvelle fois n'hésitez pas à
consulter les différents sites internet
et à vous rapprocher des services de la
vie scolaire
les mères qui s'organise également pour
la distribution de protection auprès de
leurs habitants toujours à montigny le
bretonneux notamment une distribution a
eu lieu ce jeudi matin à l'hôtel de
ville est la commune a commandé 35 mille
masques qu'elle remet aujourd'hui et
demain dans les neuf quartiers de la
ville une personne par foyer est invité
à venir récupérer les protections la
municipalité ira aussi déposer et des
masques dans les boîtes aux lettres des
publics qui ne peuvent pas se déplacer
un budget de 75 mille euros a été
dégagée pour cette commande les propos
sont recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude
ce sont des masques qui sont utilisables
cas soit lavables qui filtre à 90 au
lieu de 70 qui est la norme afnor
nous on a pris des masques à 90 pour 3
microns et donc on a en plus de ça une
dotation de masques enfants de 3000
masques va pas une dotation ce sont les
40 couturières bénévoles de la ville qui
ont fait 3000 masques en en quelques
jours puisqu'on leur a donné la ville a
fourni le tissu les élastiques et c est
donc les couturières ont
roduit 3000 masques entre le samedi
dernier et hier soit une distribution de
masques cette fois ci pour les micro
entrepreneurs petites et moyennes
entreprises étaient organisés également
cette semaine à la chambre des métiers
de l'artisanat
c'est à versailles du matériel distribué
par la région ile de france avec les
partenaires du tissu économique
yvelinois le reportage de nicolas landry
il ya d'abord les entreprises pour
lesquelles le déconfinement ne va rien
changer
c'est le cas de cet artisan de
fontenay-le-fleury dirigeants d'une
boulangerie avec huit salariés il a
continué son activité avec une nouvelle
organisation adaptée à la situation
aujourd'hui il vient chercher des
masques pour renforcer un stocks déjà
constitués
on avait déjà démarré ce qu'on a on a
les gants en a le gel on a tout ce qu'il
faut on avait déjà tout mis en place les
barrières enfin les plaisirs
voilà et puis les règles de
distanciation donc déjà toutes équipées
pour pouvoir continuer tout simplement
puis il ya les autres sociétés
contrainte de fermer au début du
confinement exemple avec ce dirigeant
d'un institut de beauté d'elancourt dans
l'obligation de repenser son activité et
d'adopter une charte de fonctionnement
pour le déconfinement le fait d'avoir
une distanciation et des clients en
institut de beauté c'est très compliqué
ça n'existe pas puisqu'on touche
forcément la personne
donc là on est en train d'inventer
quelque chose qui n'existe pas un
terreau du hammam on va limiter le
nombre de vasques un sur deux pour avoir
en gros deux mètres carrés par personne
s'équiper en matériel sanitaire
réorganiser son activité la préparation
ou déconfinement un parcours du
combattant pour les entreprises je
trouve qu'il ya un bon sens dans
l'organisation des entreprises et des
commerces et des tpe
ça tourne plutôt bien on privilégie les
salariés qui peuvent être sur place qui
n'ont pas d'enfant ensuite on essaye
d'organiser la garde des enfants
mais si vous voulez les gens n'attendent
pas tout de l'information j'allais dire
d'état ils savent aussi se prendre en
main s'organiser la principale
préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est de
pouvoir mettre leurs salariés pour la
plupart en sécurité
ils sont assez inquiets notamment sur la
responsabilité civile et pénale du chef
d'entreprise
au total ce sont près de 80 mille
masques qui ont été distribués aux tpe
et pme des yvelines ce sont aussi des
distributions alimentaires pour les
populations dans le besoin qui sont
opérés aujourd'hui le secours populaire
des yvelines a remis des colis
alimentaires à 80 étudiants confinés
dans les sept résidences universitaires
et des yvelines une opération en
partenariat avec le crous de versailles
ce matin la vingtaine de bénévoles s'est
retrouvé sur le site de l'ue vs qu à
glux en cours pour le départ de ces
colis des colis qui sont préparés depuis
le début de la semaine
patrick jacques de dixmude pour
l'interview collectés mais exigeant sur
sept sites différents sous le
département bucs versailles elancourt
guyancourt et viroflay notamment et ils
ont été identifiés par le biais du crous
en fait le service d'hébergement du
crous qui est en lien avec les étudiants
confiné et les unions et actuellement
les étudiants confiné et du coup par cb
là ils ont détecté le plus besoin en
fait notre aide en train de confinement
et par la suite on souhaite pouvoir
pérenniser le lien avec le coup sans
période de non confinement et de
en cours au delà virus pour poursuivre
la solidarité auprès des étudiants
précaires solidarité aussi auprès de
l'agriculture secteur très mobilisés
mais aussi fortement impacté par la
crise sanitaire
rien que pour les horticulteurs les
pertes sont estimées en ile-de-france à
12 millions d'euros
dans ce contexte la région a justement
pris des mesures d'urgence est notamment
un soutien d'un million d'euros pour
développer les circuits courts favoriser
la mise en place de drive fermiers par
exemple les projets pourront être
subventionnés à hauteur de 70%
principale annonce la création d'un
programme alimentaire régionale dont une
convention a été signée ir mercredi avec
la chambre d'agriculture francilienne la
collectivité va racheter les productions
des exploitants pour les redistribuer
aux franciliens les plus démunis écouter
la présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse
nous avons décidé avec le président de
la chambre d'agriculture de la région
ile de france christophe hillairet de
créer et de mettre sur pied un programme
alimentaire régionale pour venir en aide
des plus démunis sur la base des besoins
qui vont être exprimées par les
associations à la banque alimentaire la
région financera l'achat de produits
agricoles et alimentaires auprès des
agriculteurs franciliens qui prendront à
leur charge l'organisation du sourcing
voilà je me réjouis de ce partenariat
exemplaire entre notre collectivité et
le monde agricole qui est fidèle aux
valeurs qui sont les siennes responsable
pendant la crise et solidaire dans ses
effets dramatiques
parmi les autres mesures une enveloppe
d'1 5 million d'euros débloqués pour les
horticulteurs et les pépiniéristes des
arbres et des plantes seront aussi
commandé par la région pour fleurir à
l'hélice et le nouveau siège de la
collectivité à saint-ouen valérie
pécresse qui était auditionné hier par
les sénateurs c'est elle qui est
également président d'ile-de-france
mobilité a répondu aux questions de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
sur la thématique des transports
l'occasion de préciser le dispositif à
partir du 11 mai elle la région a signé
un accord avec l'état et les syndicats
pour prolonger le télétravail est étalé
les horaires des salariés
l'élu a précisé également qu'une
attestation employeur sera exigée dans
les transports aux heures de pointe et
que l'entraidé gare sera filtrée un
retour à 100% du trafic
elle n'interviendra pas avant la fin m
concernant les transports plus
spécifiquement à saint quentin en
yvelines pour ce qui est des lignes
encore en service la ligne n et le rer
c'est fonctionneront à 50% et pour la
ligne u les horaires seront adaptés sur
les conditions de voyage il sera
obligatoire de porter un masque et un
siège sur deux sera neutralisée et si
vous empruntez le réseau des bus sachez
que 100% des lignes devraient circuler à
l'exception de celles dédiées au
transport scolaire qui se feront au cas
par cas et là aussi elle masque
obligatoire et siège condamné il faudra
également monté par l'arrière des
véhicules et la vente de tickets sera
interdite à bord comment se prépare
justement la région ile de france au
début du déconfinement et surtout
comment fait-elle pour agir auprès des
entreprises nous avons posé la question
à alexandra dublanche l'entretien est
menée par wilfrid richy le déconfinement
annoncé pour le 11 mai comment se
prépare l'ile-de-france à la relance de
son activité alexandra dublanche élus
yvelinoise à sartrouville élu à la
région vice présidente en charge de
l'économie et de l'attractivité était
avec nos bons jours
borja avant de rentrer dans le détail
des mesures d'accompagnement aux
entreprises qui ont été mises en place
peut-être un sentiment plus globale
avez vous des inquiétudes sur la reprise
du 11 mai on sent bien que le
déconfinement ne sera encore que très
partielle à nous notre enjeu à la région
ile de france c'est évidemment le goulot
d'étranglement que représentent les
transports on essaie de mettre en place
avec valérie pécresse toutes les
conditions pour que cela se passe du
mieux possible cela commence nous avons
demandé dès le départ le port
obligatoire du masque ça veut dire
évidemment équipé les usagers on a déjà
distribué 1,6 million de masques ces
deux dernières semaines dans plus de 220
gares d'île de france
on a également demandé à l'état cinq
mille personnes forces de sécurité en
renfort pour nous aider à réguler
l'antre des dégâts par ailleurs nous
avons signé hier
avec les organisations patronales
syndicales les organisations de
transport la région et l'état une charte
pour encourager les entreprises à
maintenir le télétravail pour ceux qui
le peuvent a également aussi utiliser le
lissage des heures de pointe
c'est à dire au lieu d'arriver à 9
heures j'arrive entre 6h30 et 7h30 et je
repars entre 15h30 et 16h30 par exemple
avec une attestation a signé par
l'employeur
et donc voilà puis on va mettre des
distributeurs de masse de gel dans dans
les gares donc c'est ce qu'on essaye de
mettre en place pour lundi collectivités
effectivement économiques et liées au
transport donc voilà pour les mesures
qui ont été pour été prises
jusqu'aujourd'hui la région a lancé
plusieurs raids pour les entreprises
dans le cadre de son plan d'urgence si
on peut déjà évoqué le fait le pré rond
par exemple c'était avec bébé pays
france un prêt à taux zéro tout à fait
ce prêt a été lancée à mardi c'est un
prêt donc effectivement à taux zéro
entre 10000 et 300000 euros pour les
entreprises jusqu'à 250 salariés
il y à un différé de remboursement de 2
ans et ensuite on a sept ans pour
rembourser rembourser ce prêt avec des
pays on va mettre environ 150 millions
d'euros sur ce dispositif
il n'y a pas de caution non plus
personnelle du dirigeant le but c'est de
pallier les manques de trésorerie les
besoins de trésorerie des entreprises
les besoins d'augmentation de bfr besoin
en fonds de roulement tout ce qui est
des investissements immatériels et on
matériel et immatériel et on veut être
le plus réactif possible donc ce prêt
s'il est un fer à 50000 euros
il y aura une décision dans les trois à
cinq jours et au delà on s'engage à
donner une réponse dans les sept jours
il ya un fond de solidarité aussi je
fais un peu le point sur les différentes
mesures un fonds de solidarité jusqu'à
5000 euros pour les plus petites
entreprises devant la dix salariés
exactement ce fonds de solidarité c'est
un fonds national dans lequel la région
ile-de-france mais 150 millions d'euros
c'est pour les effectivement moins de 10
salariés ayant à moins d'un million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et qui ont
connu une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
d'au moins 50% par rapport à l'année
dernière
donc il ya eu un volet 1 qui pouvait
aller jusqu'à 1500 euros et un volet de
il faut en parler puisque la jumelle de
france ne fait pas encore assez appelle
les entrepreneurs les commerçants et or
c'est un fonds national
le volet 2 qui peut effectivement aller
jusqu'à 5000 euros pour ceux qui ont
bénéficié de la première la première
vague mais dans le même esprit est de
toutes petites entreprises du btp au
café aux commerçants associations aussi
d'ici la fin du mois de mai c'est une
avance remboursable
baptisé résilience oui alors je me mets
à la place des entrepreneurs qui nous
écoutent
on n'essaie pas de multiplier dispositif
on essaye de parler de vraiment de
répondre aux trous dans la raquette des
dispositifs existants le prêt rebond il
répond peut-être à voilà au manque du
pge du du prêt garanti et un se font
résilience c'est pour aider les plus
petits effectivement entre 0 et 20
salariés on le fait tous les territoires
d'une de france c'est à dire chaque
territoire pas la langue dans les
yvelines pourra bonifier se font mettre
un bonus pour pouvoir aider les
entreprises du territoire donc
donc voila et donc c'est vrai on est en
train de monter ce fonds de 100 millions
d'euros avec tous les territoires d'île
de france les départements on l'espère
la métropole du grand paris pour arriver
à un fonds pour aider les plus petits
les commerçants nos commerçants nos
artisans nos tpe pour les aider à
rebondir
une telle question que j'allais vous
posez justement il ya une multitude
d'offres dead qui sont mises en place
actuellement l idée pour la région c'est
de maillet au mieux de ne laisser
personne de côté et de répondre aussi
bien aux besoins les plus grosses
structures que des plus petites aussi
exactement nous fait vraiment la cible
c'est surtout les plus petits mais bon
vous voyez que le pré rond va jusqu'à
250 salariés donc ça prend bien les pme
mais vraiment oui effectivement il faut
aider tout le monde a passé cette crise
et nous on essaie de rattraper ceux qui
peuvent échapper peut-être à certains
dispositifs actuels à nationaux et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on crée d'autres
dispositifs ça peut faire peur un peu
comme ça mais on essaie d'expliquer de
communiquer d'ailleurs je vous en
remercie pour que nos entrepreneurs
notamment yvelinois 1 s'en saisisse
il ya un numéro de téléphone qui va
s'afficher 01 53 85 53 85 s'allume héros
de téléphone qui a été mis en place par
la région pour justement les
entrepreneurs mais pas uniquement
toutes les autres personnes qui pour
avoir des questions sur ce qui a été mis
en place par la région depuis le début
de cette crise début du confinement
notamment depuis le 17 mars
si on peut faire un point aussi
peut-être plus générale sur l'impact de
cette crise sanitaire sur les
entreprises franciliennes aujourd'hui
pour la plupart des entreprises cette
crise sans précédent elles pourront s'en
remettre écoutez on fait tout pour
et elles le font aussi alors il ya des
secteurs qui sont particulièrement
impactés je pense évidemment au tourisme
la restauration qui ne va pas reprendre
lundi
donc c'est aussi pour ces entreprises
qu'on met en place ces dispositifs sont
au tourisme on réfléchit beaucoup aux
vacances de cet été peut-être doter les
franciliens de chèques vacances a
dépensé en ile-de-france pour aussi
contribué à la voile à la reprise du
touriste tout ce qui est vainement ciel
aussi c'est en une situation très
compliquée donc nous on essaie d'être
couteau suisse pour faire face à toutes
ces situations et que personne que tout
le monde puisse survivre un maximum de
d'entreprise et donc on pense aussi
voilà les conclusions qu'on tire de
cette crise sur la relocalisation
notamment on en parle beaucoup il ya des
maillons manquants de chaînes de
production qui a été très visible
pendant cette crise je pense à
l'industrie du médicament par exemple
mais dans tant d'autres filières et donc
nous on est déjà en discussion à peu
près depuis un mois avec ces filières
pour voir comment réorganiser nos
productions dans les yvelines je pense
ceci évidemment à l'agriculture dont je
les ai également la charge
on a vu un regain de local dans vie de
local de nos concitoyens et nous on veut
que ça perdure on a annoncé d'ailleurs
hier des mesures pour l'agriculture par
exemple sur le l'aide au financement
vous savez on a eu beaucoup drive
fermiers de la vente à la ferme donc
nous on financera région jusqu'à 70%
toutes ces structures pour qu'elle
perdure les agriculteurs on a envie
veulent se retrouver ce contact
on essaie de le faire depuis des mois
mais la crise a amplifié le phénomène
est donc ça il ya parfois quelques
points positifs de cette crise et donc
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on veut
c'est de pousser mais en moyenne
question qui subsiste en derrière tout
ça il ya beaucoup d'autres qui sont
mises en place
ça veut dire derrière nécessairement les
impôts faut bien financer tout ça
réponse vous savez quelque pécresse on a
une gestion extrêmement rigoureuse des
des fonds de la région depuis notre
arrivée on avait fait un milliard
d'euros d'économies donc on est toujours
très attentif à la façon dont on dépense
voilà on suit ses dépenses pour
l'instant tout ce que je vous cite une
et 156 millions d'euros de fonds de
solidarité les 150 millions dupré rebond
s'est pris sur le budget actuel il n'y a
pas eu on entend beaucoup parler d'
ouverture des vannes au niveau national
l'état nous c'est pas du tout le cas
toute façon on a les rondes à des règles
très strictes pour les collectivités
donc pour l'instant on essaie de
redéployer des crédits pour mais il ya
un moment il faudra faire des choix et
j'espère quand même que l'état va nous
aider à pouvoir être et c'est le cas
pour les communes aussi je suis à
sartrouville je suis élu à sartrouville
nous aider parce que pour l'instant les
communes prennent à leur compte toutes
ces dépenses d'achat de masques
notamment aussi donc on attend vraiment
une aide de l'état là dessus une toute
dernière question puisque vous l'avez
rappelé vous êtes est lui aussi dans les
yvelines à sartrouville la réouverture
des écoles dans votre commune se passera
comme en écouter un nous notre mère a
voulu rang alors ils appliquent
strictement le protocole fournis par
l'état et ensuite il laisse la
possibilité aux parents il est trés dans
une approche plutôt souple de cette
reprise de l'école et je pense que c'est
la bonne approche
il faut pas forcer les parents il ya
beaucoup d'angoissé donc chacun fait
comme il le peut comme il le veut c'est
important quand même de reprendre les
écoles pour reprendre l'activité
économique
c'est important mais il faut le faire de
façon la plus agile possible en étant à
l'écouté des besoins aussi des
enseignants qui sont très anxieux
des parents et puis pour le bien-être de
nos enfants merci beaucoup alexandra
dublanche vice présidente à la région
ile de france en charge notamment du
développement économique merci merci le
tribunal judiciaire de versailles se
prépare également à la fin du
confinement pendant ces huit dernières
semaines l'institution a continué de
fonctionner dans les yvelines
le procureur de la république fait le
bilan de cette période et nous explique
les dispositions prises pour la suite
le tribunal judiciaire de versailles a
fonctionné autant qu'il pouvait pendant
ces semaines de confinement sur le plan
juridictionnel pénale aux termes
d'audiences correctionnelles la
juridiction fonctionner à peu près à 50
% de sa capacité
ce que le parquet et la juridiction
pénale a été amené à traiter trait
essentiellement ce sont les infractions
au confinement sous leur forme
délictuelle bien entendu puisque en
matière contraventionnelle la
juridiction n'avait pas en connaître
sous forme de procès verbal électronique
nous avons traité aussi s est en train
de monter progressivement pour reprendre
la tête je dirais les violences
intrafamiliales
que ce soit des violences au sein du
couple que ce soit parfois des violences
sur les enfants ou sur les ascendants
d'ailleurs nous avons été amenés à 1,6 à
traiter un certain nombre d'infractions
liées on va dire globalement tendu à ce
qu'on appelle les violences urbaines
avec une gravité relative
heureusement même si on a eu à déplorer
un cas tout à fait dramatique d'une
petite fille de cinq ans qui a été
atteinte par un tir lors d'une d'un
échange et d'une altercation entre à
chanteloup les vignes entre les forces
de l'ordre
et puis les personnes qui les
attaquaient
cette période de nous a conduits à a
poussé à son maximum
quelque chose qui à mon avis est une
qualité intrinsèque du magistrat
peut-être encore plus du parquetier qui
est le sens de l'adaptation de la
décision rapide et de l'adaptation une
juridiction
c'est une dyarchie donc je suis seul à
vous parler mais j'ai travaillé avec le
président de cette juridiction
élu avec moi et avec l'ensemble du
personnel dirigeant de greffe et ça nous
enseigne de manière encore plus certaine
que la collectivité bien plus
intelligente et bien plus efficace quand
elle fonctionne effectivement de cette
manière là on s'est fait un petit peu
malmené les juridictions par des
articles de presse qui rapportait des
propos notamment de membres de certains
barreaux comme quoi la justice elle
était planqué les magistrats étaient
planqués
heureusement que les greffes était là et
encore eu aussi se faisait vilipendé
mais en gros personne ne faisait rien et
tout le monde était caché ça c'est
inadmissible et ce n'est pas la réalité
la juridiction versaillaise au premier
chef puisque c'est celle que je veux
mettre en valeur elle s'est adaptée n a
pas à rougir de son bilan
c'est un des confinement qui va prendre
en compte pour l'organisation et la vie
du tribunal à partir de lundi de données
très essentiel en fait que sont d'une
part l'absolue nécessité de respecter
les règles de distanciation sociale et
gestes barrières qui s'applique à nous
et à ce public que nous n'avions plus
jusqu'à présent mais qui va revenir dans
la juridiction donc physiquement nous
allons installer des barrières
nous allons donner des masques à ceux
qui n'en auront pas mais nous demandons
à ce que par exemple les personnes qui
viennent au tribunal soit muni d'un
masque et seules les personnes munies
d'un masque pourront rentrer vous avez
par exemple un certain nombre
d'audiences qui sont des audiences de
cabinet par exemple les juges aux
affaires familiales
les juges des enfants les délégués du
procureur et à tout un tas de
fonctionnement au sein de la juridiction
où les règles de distanciation sociale
ne pourront plus être respectée sur les
anciennes manières de fonctionner donc
il faut qu'on utilise de manière
différente
l'espace dont on dispose la deuxième
contrainte qui s'impose à nous ses
vis-à-vis des effectifs phase est celle
qui est relative aux effectifs dont nous
disposons tant du côté des magistrats
que du côté des fonctionnaires cette
communauté de travail là elle est comme
les gens de l'extérieur soumises à des
difficultés éventuelles ou transport des
difficultés de garde d'enfants des
problèmes de maladies des problèmes et
c'est donc nous mêmes nous allons
adapter notre activité aux effectifs
dont nous disposons avant de vous
laisser on a peut-être tendance à
l'oublier en cette période particulière
mais demain c'est le 8 mai date
importante cette année puisqu'il s'agit
du 75e anniversaire de la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale en europe à deux
cérémonies bien évidemment pour les
communes en raison des mesures
sanitaires mais plusieurs ont prévu tout
de même et des hommages attrape par
exemple une cérémonie et virtuel sera
organisée à partir de 10h la ville donne
rendez vous sur facebook pour suivre les
commémorations voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale d'information
lequel revient à partir du lundi 11 mai
sur tv 78 d'ici là portez vous bien et
restez chez vous c'est très important
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]